Hello world it Saroj.
And today we're going to talk about a
cryptocurrency called car Dano. Well,
the coin itself is called Adda by the
blockchain that it's a ports is called
Cardinal. And it was created
by the co founders of etherium.
You've got Charles Hoskinson,
which is,
he's basically like the Steve Jobs of
Crypto and you've got Jeremy would.
So both of these guys have been in the
space for five plus years and they've
seen a lot of the problems that happen
with cryptocurrencies and they took all
of those problems and they decided to
make one single solution called court car
Dano, which I've been researching a lot
lately. And I think the platform is very,
very cool. So in this video I'm
going to talk about its architecture,
how it works, how it's delegated,
proof of stake algorithm works,
and how it's different
from bitcoin and ethereum.
So let's start off with bitcoin.
You always got to start off with Bitcoin,
right when it comes to cryptocurrencies.
So there've been three generations of
distributed ledger technology so far.
The first generation was
obviously Bitcoin, right?
And You got light coin and
all the initial, all coins.
But the idea was always the same.
Can we create decentralized money?
And the answer was yes.
Right?
So money that doesn't require
a trusted third party. No,
I'm not going to explain how bitcoin
works. I've done that in previous videos,
but I will say that bitcoin allows Alice
to send money to Bob without needing a
trusted third party,
right?
We had the traditional way to do this
and involved a bank, a clearinghouse,
the ACH network, all of these different
networks that were pre-internet, right?
And so it took,
it takes some time for Alison,
send money to Bob if he's in a different
country because it's requiring all
these different old,
old world protocols.
But there's one thing
that bitcoin cannot do.
What if Alice wants to send money to
Bob? Only if Bob Mo's her lawn, right?
So you've got to have a network that's
able to communicate with the real world,
some kind of lawn mowed API or something
like that where the transaction can
tell if a Bob mode Ellis his lawn and,
and if,
and only if that happened,
it will release the funds and send
them to [inaudible] from Alice.
But bitcoin does not allow for this.
However,
a lot of people don't realize that bitcoin
does have its own scripting language,
right? So Toshi implemented a
scripting language in Bitcoin, however,
it's very limited. And that's for
security reasons. Mostly. Uh, for example,
the Bitcoin scripting language does
not allow for looping at all. Uh,
so this is an example of a bitcoin script.
It's a very trivial example.
You just have three variables here. I add
them together and then I returned them.
So that's an example of bitcoin script.
It's useful for things like escrows,
but not very detailed. Escrows are
anything more than just, you know,
multiday multisignature transactions.
So enter etherium.
So a theory on came from a problem
with bitcoin has in can we decentralize
everything else in the way that we can
decentralize transactions without the
need for a third party? Can we also
decentralized computation? Right?
Can we decentralize the, the way of
building an application in general.
So I like to quote metallic,
the founder of Etherium,
when I say comparing bitcoin to ethereum
is kind of like comparing an apple to a
phone. They're just completely
different technologies. So if you're in,
for example, is if you're IOM
is a programmable blockchain,
that's the way you can think of it.
It's a programmable blockchain.
And you might be saying, wait a second.
Bitcoin has its own scripting language.
It's programmable. It's, it is, but
it's very, very limited. If barium is a,
has a Turing complete programming
language called solidity,
Turing complete means it's able to do
everything. Loops is one trivial example.
Recursion is another one. But anything
that any programming language can do,
if they're eoms solidity can do.
It's Kinda like when javascript
came to the browser, for example,
before Javascript, all web pages were
static, right? You had html, you had CSS.
But once javascript entered the browser,
we were able to do dynamic
things and had much, much,
many more features than we could before,
right?
So it allows for
customizable transactions.
And what I mean by that is code on the
blockchain. So Heroku is a great example.
[inaudible] you've got Hiroku, you code
some script, you upload it to Heroku.
Heroku is that centralized source
for that code. It runs a computation.
And then all nodes that are connecting
to your web app with your Heroku backend
have to connect to this central
source. However, with etherium,
you don't push that coat to Hiroku.
You Post,
you push it to all the
nodes in the network via a
transaction. That's your push,
your push is a transaction.
And then all the nodes that are
running a full etherium, um,
client have to process that
computation, um, block.
And so then once that code is run,
all the nodes in the network
have to compute that code, right?
So it's decentralized computation.
And this allows for
unstoppable applications,
applications that no one can shut down.
This has a range of use cases from
financial transactions to health care,
all sorts of things. Um, but
I won't go into that either.
Here's an example of a theory.
I'm script right here. Solidity.
It's much more readable.
It looks kind of like python,
but this is a proof of
existence script in etherium.
You've got one function that's
returning, uh, another function.
So that's an example of solidity.
But etherium as awesome as it is,
has its own problems, right? So
etherium has governance problems,
Aka the hard fork or in the soft fork,
it's got security problems, Aka six.
Scalability, how do we solve
these problems, right? How
do we solve scalability?
How do we solve interoperability
and how do we solve sustainability?
I'm going to go into each of
these three points in a second.
But if we look at the blockchain history,
Bitcoin allow for a distributed ledger
and it allowed for the advent of
cryptocurrency. Ethereum allowed for
the same two things. In addition,
it allowed for smart contracts.
Now,
the third generation of blockchain has
to do more than both of them combined.
What can it do?
Well,
we know that any kind of programmable
blockchain is touring complete.
It allows for building all sorts of
decentralized applications. However,
the is not the number of
features that the problem is.
It's infrastructure. How do we
improve that infrastructure? Right?
So one huge problem when it comes
to blockchain's a scalability.
And these are the three points
that cardinal aims to solve.
I'm going to go into how it aims
to solve all three of them, right?
So for scalability,
there are different proposals for
solving Bitcoin scalability, right?
What if we shift the burden onto the
users via trusted intermediaries for
etherium, what if we tweak the
tuning parameters, limited head room,
or do security margins? And then
there's entirely different, um, uh,
solutions like semi-closed groups
like the ripple protocol or stellar,
you lose your openness,
but you have public transparency benefits.
And then the hardest solution is to
rethink your architecture entirely.
And that's where third
generation cryptocurrencies
are coming into play right?
Now, I talked a bit about
Ibotta, right? So I,
Yoda just discards the idea
of a blockchain entirely
and moves to a directed
[inaudible] graph, right? So it's, it's,
it's instead of a linear data structure,
it's a dag data structure,
but that's just one way to solve it.
It's not that the idea of a
blockchain is inherently bad,
it's just that the infrastructure around
it can cause these problems, right?
Having a blockchain that uses
the proof of work, for example,
requires huge amounts of computation,
way too much, a lot of electricity,
a lot of scalability problems,
having all the nodes have to download a
full copy of every transaction in and of
itself is just not able to
scale, right? What if we have,
you know what, if in five years we have
billions and trillions of transactions,
you're telling me if I want to be a minor,
I had to download all of those
transactions to my laptop.
That's a lot of transactions. Hence
the problem with scalability, right?
And so that brought the
blockchain protocol.
The bitcoin protocol specifically relies
upon many nodes pro possessing a full
copy of the blockchain data,
and so this restriction
prevents cryptocurrencies
from scaling to compete with
legacy financial systems
like visa for example. Right?
The bitcoin network allows for
seven transactions per second.
Visa is something on the,
you know,
just orders of magnitude more like
10,000 plus transactions per second.
So what cardinal offers as a solution
to this is it's own proof of stake
protocol.
It's,
it's actually a delegated proof of stake
protocol and they call it aura boreaus,
which I'm going to go into
at the end of the video.
There's another problem with scalability.
It's not just about the number
of transactions per second,
it's also about bandwidth.
So when it comes to bandwidth,
how much data can we pipe through
these networks all at once.
And so their solution for this is using
a network architecture called Rena,
which is short for recursive
Internet work architecture,
which I'll go into a
bit as well at the end.
And the last problem when it comes to
scalability is data scale rights. How,
how do we scale the amount of data
that it's, that is in the network,
how do we structure that data?
So everything is as fast as possible.
And there are several solutions for this.
There's pruning, there's compression,
there's partitioning.
So there's a lot of problems when it
comes to this and there's a lot of
proposals on how to fix this.
So interoperability, right?
So this is the second major problem
we've got scalability, interoperability,
and the last one, which is sustainability.
So when it comes to interoperability,
whenever we want to send
cross border payments using
the legacy financial system,
one bank will send money to another bank,
right?
And if they have this partnership,
They have these protocols to send
money between different banks.
They have partnerships, and
they have all these, you know,
Kyc and all these different
compliance protocols.
So they'd been around for a while.
And so it's very difficult for Bitcoin
to communicate with the theory.
[inaudible] for example, and
other old coins. However,
for banks it's easy because they built
these protocols over many, many decades.
Um,
and so in the traditional financial world,
how is a bank supposed to talk to Bitcoin?
Forget about Bitcoin,
talking to about talking
to other altcoins.
How do you get a bank like ing to talk
to the bitcoin network, for example?
This is very hard, right? Banks need
these compliance regulations. Kyc,
you know,
there's all these different compliance
regulations at other banks are really
good at complying with that.
Cryptocurrencies are not,
they're just these networks run by
developers and they're not as mature.
So we would need these
compliance protocols built
into these cryptocurrencies
for the traditional financial world to
be able to talk to the new financial
world. And we need cross
chain transactions without
the need for a third party,
right? So right now the way that bitcoin
can talk to theory them is by using a
centralized party like
Coinbase for example,
or crack in or any of these exchanges.
So these are kind of temporary solutions
to transfer of value between different
currencies, but they're centralized
solution in and of themselves, right?
So we need a way to allow for value
transfer between cryptocurrencies without
the need for a third party.
And we also need three other
kind of smaller details.
We need metadata.
That is who we sending the transaction
and have that be opt in or opt out based
on whether or not you want to be visible.
We need attribution who sent what
rights and we need compliance.
Like I talked about before,
a Kyc. And so for Bitcoin,
there's this idea of the side chain
proposal where you peg an alt coin to
bitcoin and this would require a change
inside of the bitcoin network that did
the developers have to accept.
And there's this whole theory behind
how side chains can work, et cetera. Uh,
but it's in the works.
Now lastly,
there's one more problem when it comes
to cryptocurrencies in general and that's
sustainability.
Okay?
So how do we sustain a network
over a period of years,
if not decades? So one way to do this
is by using the ICO model, right?
So the initial coin offering model,
this is a way for the network to
gain a huge sum of money all at once.
But the problem is that this is a
huge sum of money all at once, right?
This can walk up, no matter how big it
is, eventually it's going to run out.
So it's not a very sustainable
model for fundraising,
for the developer to the network and
for the users and the contributors.
It's just not sustainable.
So a better way of sustainably funding
a network is to the idea of of a
treasury, right? A treasury system.
So one cryptocurrency that did this
very well is the dash protocol.
So with the Dash Protocol did is it has
this treasury that is this kind of volt
of savings that the network holds.
And so the users can vote on how that and
how the money in the Treasury is spent
through voting,
right?
So you have all these different proposals
for things that would grow the dash
network like launching dash in Zimbabwe
promoting dash to 200,000 people,
let millions of Chinese investors
on who'll be invest in Dash,
all these different things,
right dash documentary and users can
vote on how much cryptocurrency they want
have to be allocated
towards these proposals.
So that's just a more
sustainable way of doing things.
And cardinal has adapted this
model of using a treasury, right?
So you know,
how should we go about something,
how do we solve the problem of governance?
And this is a,
this is a very hard problem,
right? With, even with etherium,
there has been this idea of the
hard fork and the soft fork.
To explain a little bit about
the difference between the two.
Hard forking is not backwards compatible.
So it's a completely different type of
network. Soft forking is right. So it's a,
it's,
it's a change to the network that the
old nodes would have to upgrade too or
else they're not a part of
the network ever anymore.
So let's talk a bit about cardinal and
now that we've talked about the problems
with blockchains so far.
So the team so far consists of
Charles Hoskinson and Jeremy would,
both of these are cofounders of Atherium.
These guys have been around for a while.
So they've,
they've seen the problems that come from
both Turing complete and non complete
blockchains.
And so they claim that it's the first
blockchain platform to evolve out of a
scientific philosophy, philosophy and a
research first driven approach. I mean,
if you look at their team, they've
got a bunch of PHD's. Um, it's a,
it's a very solid team,
which is, which is cool.
And it's backed by three independent
entities. The car, Donald Foundation,
which is a nonprofit, um, the Io aged k,
which is a crypto studio,
started by both of these two and Emergo,
which is a cardinal
specific blockchain studio.
So it's got a lot of money that's
been funded into a lot of resources,
development and, and funds. So when
it comes to it to architecture,
one thing that I think is very
interesting is the fact that it uses,
Haskell has a programming language.
It's the first blockchain to be coated
in Haskell and in Haskell. If you're,
if you love math, Haskell is a
language for you. But basically, uh,
Haskell is a language that
allows for a prototyping.
Very complicated math
equation is very fast.
And I've got a little example for you
here that I just pulled from their
repository to see.
Just so you can see what Haskell looks
like in the context of a blockchain.
So it's the first cryptocurrency
to be written in Haskell.
It also has to scripting languages.
One of them is solidity.
So this is another example of solidity.
Very readable language.
Looks a lot like python. And if
you're familiar with python, you'll,
you'll catch up with solidity very fast.
Also,
it's composed of two
independent blockchain layers.
You've got the settlement layer,
and then you've got the control layer,
and I'll talk about the
difference between the two.
Cardinal separates the accounting from
the story behind it by creating two
protocol layers.
The settlement and the control layer.
That settlement layer will have.
The unit will have a unit of account
or value while the control layer runs
computations in the
form of smart contracts.
So right now we can look
at the settlement layer.
The computation layer is still in
the works. It's still to be built.
So let's take a look at
the settlement layer,
which we can look at on get hub right now,
but it's a standalone blockchain
powered by the actual Ada token,
which you can buy right
now and or boreaus there.
A proof of stake algorithm allows for
features such as delegation and side
chains,
which allows for interoperability.
So if we look at this a get hub
repository right now, we can see the wood,
the settlement layer looks like the
whole thing is coated in Haskell. Uh,
it doesn't have that much internal talky
documentation on the get hub website.
But if you want to see documentation,
they've got the separate website called
Card Donald Docs, which we can look at.
A lot of it is just reasons why
you'd want to use card Donno,
but it's also got installation
instructions as well for
supporting platforms.
You can install their, uh, their
wallet on windows and Mac Os. Uh,
and it's got a bunch of
descriptions of how APIs work,
how the, how the transactions work, how
the steak is distributed. It's got a lot.
So it's got a lot of documentation,
which is a good thing. Uh,
and I can make another video on that to
go really into those technical details,
but check out the get hub repository and
check out that technical documentation.
Now the computation layer
is what they want to build.
So this is kind of a future thing,
but it's where information contained in
this settlement layer is processed or
computed in particular transactions.
So it's this smart contract layer.
Tbd is just,
I mean Tldr,
it's a smart contract layer and so it
never touches or wait for the CSL layer
except for when a reference point is
necessary and runs an implementation of
their proof of stake algorithm just like
the settlement layer. So they both do.
So let me talk a bit about Ora Boris.
Now they're their consensus algorithm.
So when it comes to proof of work,
the way proof of work works is you
have the probability of mining a block
depending on how much
computational work a minor does.
And so payout becomes smaller and smaller
for bitcoin miners and there's less
incentive to avoid a 51% attack.
And they,
these POW systems become these powerful
mining communities that tend to become
centralized.
So the way proof of stake works is
instead of saying it's all about computing
power, it's about how much
money you have in the network,
how much stake you have in the network.
So a person can mind,
depending on how many coins they ho hold.
So depending on how much stake
they have in the network,
and the POS system makes any
51% attack more expensive.
And so pos systems are more decentralized,
but must work hard to build
communities around their coins, right?
You don't want centralization in terms
of only these people have, you know,
this much steak. So when it comes
to delegated proof of stake,
and this is what Ora boreaus implements,
voting power is determined
by how much stake you have.
It's not just about how much mining
power, it's about voting power, right?
So a whale that owns 100,000 tokens has
much more voting power than a minnow
that only owns a hundred tokens.
Right?
And so based on how many tokens do you
have, your voting power increases, right?
So it's, it's kind of, it's, it's, it
facilitates the decentralized elections,
have a quorum of consensus notes.
So it's not completely decentralized.
It's not totally centralized.
It's a mix between the two.
It's kind of like liquid democracy,
if you've heard that term before,
but it's delegated proof of stake.
You've got some delegates ride that
people vote for in the network,
and if the delegate is corrupt,
everything is transparent,
then you just fire the delegate and
find a new delegate, right? So that,
that's kind of what they do.
Bad actors are fired and it removes the
requirements for widespread storage of
the entire chain.
So not every node has to download
a full copy of the blockchain,
which speeds up speeds up transactions,
right? It solves that scalability issue.
And so these consensus Dodes can run
more traditional protocols developed over
the last 20 years to accommodate the
needs of large infrastructure providers
like Google and Facebook that are more
centralized because these notes have been
elected democratically by the network
and it reduces resource requirements,
which makes it easier to,
for multiple quorums concurrently
to partition transactions.
Two different forums. So, uh, the,
the other part is the recursive
internet work architecture.
And this solves the problem of bandwidth.
So Rina is actually pretty complex.
There's a lot of,
there's,
there's a lot of theory behind it and
they're actually still developing it,
but it's been around for 10 years.
But essentially it's an alternative
to TCP IP that is more suited for
decentralized applications.
So it's,
it's better suited in TCP IP is four
nodes that are completely decentralized,
right? So in the end of this video, I
want to go into how you can buy car Dano.
So there's this great link here called
get crypto.info/car Dano and they've got
the step by step tutorial on how
to buy car Donno. But the first,
the first step is you want to download
their wallet, which is data list.
I hope I said that right data list.
Uh,
but you've the first seconds for you
to download their wallet. Don't worry,
they have it for windows,
they have it for Mac.
So go ahead and download their wallet.
You can run the program and once
you've synced with the blockchain,
you've created your personal wallet,
you created your pass phrase,
then you can go, you can pick any theory.
I'm exchange to buy some material.
Or You could buy some bitcoin and then
exchange it from their Coinbase is
another example. But this is a great link
for that. Get the wallet download it.
I think this is,
this cryptocurrency has a lot of promise
and I hope you found this video useful.
Please subscribe for
more programming videos,
and for now I'm going to study
some networking protocols,
so thanks for watching.